>> Sean: JOINING US NOW, LOTS
OF BREAKING NEWS.
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN RON
DeSANTIS I'M HOPING WILL BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT
STATE OF FLORIDA, THE SUNSHINE
STATE.
FULL DISCLOSURE FOR YOU DOPES
OVER AT MSNBC, AND SARAH CARTER,
LET'S START WITH YOU.
WHILE I WAS SPEAKING WITH YOU
LAST NIGHT, AND WE WERE SPEAKING
TO OTHER PEOPLE AND WE WERE BOTH
WORKING OUR RESOURCES, AND THEN
AGAIN THIS MORNING AT 7:00,
THERE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
RELEASED DOCUMENTS FROM THE DOJ
EARLY IN THE MORNING, THEN THEY
PULLED THEM BACK.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THE DOD GA FIELD TO MENTION
THAT WHEN THEY ISSUED A PRESS
RELEASE -- THE DOJ, SAYING THEY
WOULD TURN OVER DOCUMENTS NEXT
WEEK OR AT LEAST ALLOW CONGRESS
TO REVIEW DOCUMENTS NEXT WEEK
EITHER MONDAY OR TUESDAY, AND
ASK MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY HAD
REQUESTED ON APRIL 24TH, WHICH
WAS A SPECIFIC DOCUMENTATION BY
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD BASICALLY SHED LIGHT
ON THE ENTIRE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
IT IS THESE DOCUMENTS THAT THE
DOJ AND FBI ARE RETURNING TO
TURN OVER TO LAWMAKERS.
THEY HAVE BATTLED WITH THEM ON
MAY 24TH, REMEMBER THAT MEETING
THAT THEY HAD TO WEAR THE DOJ
AND FBI WERE SUPPOSED TO SHARE
DOCUMENTS WITH NUNEZ AND
REPRESENTATIVE TREY GOWDY AND
OTHERS, AND THEY DID NOT.
THEY IN FACT TOLD THEM THAT THEY
WOULD NOT SHARE THOSE DOCUMENTS
WITH INVESTIGATORS ON THEIR
COMMITTEE.
SO THIS HAS BEEN A
BACK-AND-FORTH BATTLE.
THEY REFUSED TO TURN THEM OVER
THIS MORNING AND INSTEAD ISSUING
A PRESS RELEASE LATE LAST NIGHT
THAT NOBODY WAS AWARE OF EXCEPT
FOR THE REPORTERS.
BUT THE CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS
WERE LEFT IN THE DARK.
THEY HEADED TO CAPITOL HILL AND
WERE WAITING FOR THE DOCUMENTS,
AND ONCE AGAIN, THEY WEREN'T
THERE.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, I GOT SOME
BREAKING NEWS IF I CAN THROW THE
SITE YOU WILL.
THIS WAS IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE HEADLINE IS, JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SEES AS TIMES
REPORTER'S EMAILS AND PHONE
RECORDS IN LEAK INVESTIGATION.
OFFICIALS SECRETLY SEIZING A
YEAR WORTH OF "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTER'S PHONE AND EMAIL
RECORDS THIS YEAR AND
INVESTIGATION OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION LEAKS.
EXCUSE ME, DON'T WE HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT HERE?
BY THE WAY, I NEVER THOUGHT I'D
BE DEFENDING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THEY DO
SUCK.
BUT WAIT A MINUTE, THEY DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT TO THIS REPORTERS
NOTES AND RECORDS.
ARE THEY ALLOWED TO PROTECT
THEIR SOURCES?
DO WE HAVE FREEDOM OF PRESS?
THAT SOUNDS SCARY TO ME, WHAT'S
YOUR REACTION?
>> IT'S ALSO AGAINST THE
BACKDROP, NO ONE HAS BEEN
PROSECUTED WHO HAS ACTUALLY DONE
LEAKING SINCE THIS
ADMINISTRATION TOOK OVER.
REMEMBER MICHAEL FLYNN AT
INTERCEPT, THE PFIZER INTERCEPT,
THAT WAS LEAKED GRATUITOUSLY BY
SOMEBODY, PROBABLY AN OBAMA
HOLDOVER.
THERE HAVE BEEN A CASCADE OF
LEAKS AND NO ONE HAS BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ANY OF THOSE
THINGS.
I NEED MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY IS HAPPENING HERE.
I KNOW THERE IS A FORMER STAFFER
ON THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE THAT IS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE INDICTED.
I'M NOT SURE IF IT WAS WORKING
FOR A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN,
ALTHOUGH I HAVE MY GUESTS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU HAVE
A SERIES OF LEAKS AND NO
ACCOUNTABILITY UP TO THIS POINT.
>> Sean: I WILL TELL YOU, THE
NEWS MEDIA, AND THEY WRITE THIS
IN THE TIMES PIECE, MINING A
RECORD FOR SOURCES WITH A
MASSIVE INTRUSION INTO THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
SARAH CARTER, WE WORKED SOURCES
LAST NIGHT AND IT'S NONE OF
THEIR BUSINESS WHO WE TALK TO OR
WHO YOU TALK TO, WHO I TALK TO.
MUELLER DOESN'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
THIS INFORMATION.
>> Sarah: ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT OVERALL,
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING HERE,
LOOK.
JAMES CLAPPER HAS NOW BEEN OUTED
PRETTY MUCH AS SOMEONE WHO THE
CONGRESS BELIEVES HAD LEAKED
INFORMATION TO CNN.
WE KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT
CONVERSATIONS              'S
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS WERE
LINKED TO THE MEDIA, BUT THAT
DOES NOT GIVE THE RIGHT FOR THE
DOJ TO START MINING REPORTERS'
TELEPHONE NUMBERS, AND
INFORMATION TO TRY TO FIND OUT
WHO WAS THE LEAKER.
I THINK THEY PRETTY MUCH KNOW
WHERE THE LEAKS ARE COMING FROM.
GIVE POLYGRAPHS.
>> Sean: MAYBE THERE IS A LEAK
AT THEIR OWN OFFICE.
>> Sarah: EXACTLY.
IF MIKE FLYNN GAVE SOME
POLYGRAPHS TO FIND OUT WHO WAS
LEAKING INSIDE OF THE DOJ OR THE
OFFICE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION,
THESE ARE HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
LEAKS.
>> Sean: THIS IS HUGE NEWS AND
I'M JUST PUTTING THIS TOGETHER.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," EVEN THEIR
OWN LEADERSHIP IS COMMENTING ON
THIS.
MAYBE THEY WILL REALIZE THAT
PEOPLE LIKE SEAN HANNITY AND
SARAH CARTER AND GREGG JARRETT
AND SO MANY OF US WERE RIGHT,
BECAUSE WE POINTED OUT PFIZER
ABUSES, LYING TO PFIZER COURT
JUSTICES, OMISSION BY LYING TO
PFIZER COURT JUSTICES, AND,
HILLARY CLINTON'S CRIMES, AND
THE DUAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THIS
COUNTRY, ONE FOR HILLARY, AND
FIXING INVESTIGATIONS WITH
EVERYTHING ASSOCIATED WITH THIS.
THAT HAS BEEN OUR POINT THE
ENTIRE TIME.
HOW DO WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS?
>> AND COME UP THEY FIGHT TOOTH
AND NAIL TO PROVIDE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE TRUTH ABOUT
ACTIVITIES.
ROSENSTEIN, AS SARAH SAID IT,
EVEN JUST LAST NIGHT WAS
REFUSING TO TURN OVER THESE
DOCUMENTS.
THEY ARE BREAKING CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS SAYING, THIS
IS EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT THE FBI
TO DO.
IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN, SO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO DOCUMENTS,
SHOW CONGRESS, SO WE CAN SEE HOW
GOOD OF A JOB YOU DID.
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE NOT
WILLING TO DO THAT TELLS ME THAT
THERE WERE PROBLEMS FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING OF THIS SO-CALLED
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION.
THEY WON'T SHOW US THE
PAPADOPOULOS STUFF, THEY WON'T
SHOW US THE INFORMATION ABOUT
HELPER.
YOU HAVE TO ASK WHY THEY WON'T
COME CLEAN.
>> Sarah: WHAT WAS THE SCOPE
OF ALL OF THIS?
I THINK WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
ONE SMALL PORTION OF MASSIVE
ABUSE, AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE THE TRUTH BECAUSE OUR
COUNTRY RELIES ON THE FOUNDATION
THAT WE BUILT OURSELVES UPON AND
IT'S NOT MEANT FOR SPYING, IT'S